- A good brand is something
that you'll buy or use
the service of where you're
actually buying the story.
Finding your bliss means
finding the core of passion
and excellence within you.
Now for the first time, I
think we have the opportunity
to create a wisdom-based economy
that actually serves the needs of society.
By learning to reawaken your creativity,
you will recapture the natural enthusiasm,
energy, and wonder of youth.
- He's an author and public speaker.
He's a prominent figure
in the New Age movement.
Through his books and videos,
he's become one of the most well known
and wealthiest figures
in alternative medicine.
He's Deepak Chopra, and here is my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number 10 is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
- What we see, what we
perceive, what we hear,
what we think, what we imagine,
what we understand, what inspires us.
All of that comes from belief.
And then these beliefs
project as our world.
We actually create the world
that comes from these inner beliefs.
In turn, the world feed backs at us.
The world feeds back on us,
and it reinforces what
we already believe in.
So we see what we become, and
the world becomes who we are.
If you talk to greatliness and
this is well done research,
even by Jim Collins if you read his book.
He says that every leader in the end says
one of the following things.
"I was lucky" or "I happened
to be in the right place
at the right time".
"There were a lot of
meaningful coincidences."
Now if they happen to be
spiritual or religious,
they may use expressions
like "God was on my side",
"I seemed to be guided."
"There was a state of grace at times."
"I was being looked after."
What they're tapping into
is a deeper intelligence
that goes beyond the personal.
You might call it transpersonal,
as the transpersonal
psychologists call it.
Or you might call it archetypal,
if you're familiar with
the teachings of Carl Jung.
But what they do is they have
a relationship with a story.
That's what a good brand is, by the way.
A brand is an archetypal story.
It has themes in it.
The good guys, the bad guys.
There's a little big of intrigue.
There's mystery, there's adventure.
All the ingredients that make
a really good soap opera.
They have a relationship with that.
A good brand is something that you'll buy
or use the service of when
you're actually buying the story.
Apple is a story.
It's a very great story.
All the big brands, Nikes
shoes, it's the story
of the African-American urban hero.
One of the things I
tell leaders to do is...
What's your story?
Can you make your story emotionally
and spiritually inspiring?
People will buy your story as the brand,
as the service, as the product.
Follow your bliss does not
mean get addicted to pleasure.
Follow your bliss means
finding the core of passion
and excellence within you.
It is to pursue excellence
and ignore success.
If you do that, of course,
success will be a byproduct,
but you're expressing the highest
potential within yourself.
And when you do that,
you lose track of time,
you experience ecstasy,
and when you express that,
there's a need in society for
that particular expression.
When society sees that, it honors you.
It makes you a hero.
The biggest challenge for all businesses
is to restore real business.
The economic meltdown was
something that happened
because we had lost the
true purpose of business.
What's the true purpose of business?
Even in business school,
it's not well defined.
They say the purpose of business
is to increase shareholder value.
That's a ridiculous thing.
The purpose of business
is to help society,
to serve the needs of society.
The purpose of business
is to serve the interests
of all that are considered stakeholders.
That includes the community
and the larger ecosystem.
We created an economy, which
was based on spending money
that people had not earned
to buy things that they
did not need to impress
people that they did not like.
Of the $2.9 trillion that are circulating
in the world's markets,
less than two percent
was going to provide goods and services.
The rest was what they
called derivatives, casino.
So now for the first time, I
think we have the opportunity
to create a wisdom-based economy
that actually serves the needs of society.
If you are a businessman today,
you need to totally reinvent yourself.
You need to ask yourself what
are the wisdom-based economies
that I can participate in.
The green economies, the
alternative energies.
People who are planting trees
are making a lot of money these days.
You have to create an economy
that is based on serving
the needs of people.
The question that was asked was
how do we maximize the use of our time.
Here's my answer, and I learnt
this from Dr. Daniel Siegel,
a UCLA psychotherapist.
He says divide time in 24 hours
into the following sections.
Sleep time, meditation
time, exercise time,
relationship time, downtime,
creative and playtime,
focused work time, and when you eat.
And when you're doing
each of these things,
then just do those things.
Don't do anything else.
I thought that was very brilliant,
and I've been doing this
now for a number of years.
I sleep at least six to eight hours a day.
I meditate early in the morning
for about one and one-half hours.
I go to the gym after that.
I walk between five to 10 miles a day.
I work from about 9 o'clock to 12 noon.
I take a full hour for a mindful lunch.
I take a 20-minute walk after lunch.
Then I start working
again in the afternoon
around 1 o'clock or so, 1:30, two even.
Then I do a short meditation
at 4:30 in the evening,
5 o'clock, and I have an
early supper around six,
and I'm in bed by about 10.
Now when I'm doing this daily routine,
then I feel that my rhythms are in order.
They're connected to the
rhythms of the cosmos.
When I'm speaking to someone,
I'm present with them.
I don't check my iPhone
or my hand-held device
at the same time, because
the cortical brain
can only do one thing at a time.
So, of course, the
autonomic nervous system
can do many things at a time.
Do one thing, do it
mindfully, and do it well.
Pursue excellence and ignore success.
Stay detached and divide your
time into those quadrants.
- So apart from running
out and creating a story,
what can the viewers, right
now, do today or tomorrow
to make themselves better leaders?
- First, ask yourself those
questions that I mentioned.
Who am I, what do I
want, what kind of team
do I want to have, what's my role in it,
what are my skills and strengths,
what are the skills and
the strengths of the people
that I want to have on my team?
If people are not being fully expressive
in their unique strengths,
they lose self-esteem.
If they're not having fun.
I am also a senior scientist
at Gallup Organization,
and we find that only 20%
of people in this country
are engaged in what they do.
About 15 to 20% are actively disengaged.
They come to work unhappy,
and they make it a point
of making other people unhappy.
The rest are kind of
punching in the clock.
This costs our economy something
like $380 billion a year.
So what makes a fun, invigorating
productive environment?
Well, if your supervisor
or manager ignores you,
your rate of disengagement goes up by 45%.
If the supervisor or
manager doesn't ignore you
but criticizes you,
your rate of engagement
drops to 20%.
You would rather be criticized
because you are now being noticed.
On the other hand, if your
manager notices a single strength
that you have, your rate
of disengagement falls
to less than one percent.
This has huge economic implications.
Each of us is born as an
infinitely creative being.
As children, we use our rich imaginations
to create entire worlds,
whether we were building
sandcastles at the beach,
playing house with a collection of dolls,
or pretending to be
our favorite superhero.
But as we become adults,
many of us succumb
to the prevailing
cultural meme, or belief,
that the older we get, our
brains lose their capacity
to expand, adapt, transform, and evolve.
But it's a lie.
As numerous studies have discovered,
the brain has a quality
referred to as plasticity.
The ability to form new neural pathways
even into very old age.
The brain is fluid, flexible,
and incredibly adaptable
to new experiences.
Neuroplasticity is what
allows us to teach ourselves
a new language, learn to play the piano,
play a new sport, or learn
the latest dance move.
Although you may no
longer think of yourself
as a creative or imaginative person,
your very existence is evidence
of your innate creativity.
In every moment, you are
co-creating your reality
through your thoughts, your intentions,
your words, and your actions.
We all have unlimited creative potential
because our essential nature
is pure consciousness.
By learning to reawaken your creativity,
you will recapture the natural enthusiasm,
energy, and wonder of youth.
As the ancient vedic
sages of India observe,
the secret of immortality
is infinite flexibility and creativity.
A victim of conditioning means
that your habitual patterns
of behavior and thinking are
result of the collective psyche
and what we call normal
in the collective psyche
is actually the
psychopathology of the average.
Dull, ordinary, mundane,
always looking for fulfillment
on something outside.
If I had the right job
or had the right money,
if I had the right relationship
Whatever the right thing
then I'd be a happy person.
But it's the other way around.
If you're happy, you'll
have the right job,
you'll have the right money
and have the right success.
You'll make the right
choices for your health
and you'll have the right relationships.
- A lot of people don't
really relate business
and spirituality together.
You don't really hear about it.
How do you think it does work though?
Do you think you need that part?
- I define spirituality as self-awareness
and also as elements of
compassion, love, service,
honesty, authenticity, integrity.
I think even if you don't
relate to those values,
if you incorporate those values,
your business will thrive.
Ask yourself, what's your purpose.
What kind of contribution
do you want to make?
What creates joy and ecstasy in you?
What are the two or three
skills that you have
that when you're expressing
your unique talents and skills,
time means nothing to you?
It's not work, it's joy?
Ask yourself who are
your heroes and heroines
in history and mythology and religion,
because these are
archetypes that are seeking
to find expression through
you and incarnate through you.
Ask yourself how can this passion of mine
contribute to relationship?
Give meaning and purpose to existence?
You don't need to know the answers.
If you live the questions, then
life has an interesting way
of moving you into the answers.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Calavera Magna asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Deepak Chopra's
top 10 rules had the biggest impact,
most meaningful impact
on your life and why.
Leave it in the comments below,
and I will join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give
a quick shout out to Lukas Kramm.
Lukas, thank you so much
for picking up my book.
For those of you watching,
if you want a chance
at a shout-out in a future video,
make sure to grab the book
and also email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe in
whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you soon.
- Information expands
our awareness of what is.
So through the Google network,
which is the biggest search engine,
we expand our awareness,
but there's another thing
that people don't understand.
Our state of awareness actually
chooses the information
that we seek out.
So if my state of awareness
says I want to understand
the causes of war,
terrorism, global warming,
social injustice, economic injustice...
All the things that are
kind of surfacing now
as what's happening in Syria
and all the Middle East,
the so-called Arab Spring
occupy Wall Street,
then my state of awareness,
looking at this global picture,
will seek out the right information.
They core feed on each other.
The information expands
awareness, but the state
of awareness also expands
the information we seek.
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- And if by awareness,
I mean spirituality,
which is my definition,
then awareness has many more
components than information.
Awareness influences your moods.
If you're depressed, then
everything looks dark and bleak.
It influences your beliefs.
It influences your assumptions.
It influences your perceptions.
It influences your expectations.
So in the book, my thesis
is that all problems exist
because of what I call
"contracted awareness".
Contracted awareness
means you feel separate
from the ecosystem.
The Google network is an ecosystem.
You feel separate from the
ecosystem that nurtures
the web of relationships.
That, then, of course,
results in fear, in anxiety,
in expectations that
are Doomsday prophecies,
in assumptions that everything
is going to go wrong,
and so on and so forth.
In my mind, the analogy is you
are walking in a dark room.
You have a candle, that's
the light of your awareness,
and you keep bumping into stuff.
And so everything's a problem,
and that's your world.
But now imagine that you can expand
that candle's light of awareness,
so now you have a flashlight
and you can move around,
and everything that
seemed like an obstacle
actually has a purpose.
This has a purpose, this has a purpose,
that screen has a purpose.
So all problems are now
opportunities for some purpose.
So that's expanded awareness,
you now feel connected to
the web of relationships.
So some thoughts, some
beliefs, are limiting.
I will never be good enough.
I will never successful.
I'll never be rich.
I'll never have a good relationship.
I'm too ugly, I'm not attractive enough,
I'm not thin enough, et cetera.
Remember, these thoughts
don't belong to you.
So you have to, whenever
you have these thoughts,
you should ask yourself, is it true?
How am I so sure if this is true?
Is this thought limiting me?
How could I go beyond this limitation?
What is a thought that is more empowering?
How can I create that thought?
Better still, go into the
deepest part of your being,
which is just silence.
When the thought intrudes,
say it doesn't belong to me, let it pass.
Observe your thoughts arise and subside
like waves on the ocean.
You are not the waves.
Although you get conditioned by the waves,
you are the mighty ocean itself.
You are not just a drop in the ocean,
you are the ocean in the drop itself.
And in the depths of
the ocean is infinity.
And you are the infinite
mind, conditioned to society
and culture and religion
into the local mind.
Is this not enough to convince you
that your thoughts don't belong to you?
When you take ownership of your thoughts,
then you get bamboozled by hypnosis
of social condition.
By the hypnosis of of
cultural conditioning.
There is no originality in that.
There is no creativity in that.
There is no love in that.
It's all conditioned love.
So please please understand
that you are the infinite being.
You are the universe
having a human experience,
but the human experience is conditioned
by labels, by definitions, by evaluations,
by judgements, by opinions, and by words
that you heard as a child.
It's difficult to break
out of this prison,
because if you're in a real
prison, a so-called real prison,
at least you see the bars.
In this prison, which is the hypnosis
of social conditioning,
the hypnosis of cultural conditioning,
you are in a prison that has no walls,
and, therefore, you don't
realize that you're in a prison,
and, therefore, you have
no desire to escape.
But if you escaped, you
would find the true mind.
You would find the true self.
You would find who you really
are, and you would be free.
The ticket to freedom is
not to own your thoughts.
to find the source field
within you, which is the
source field of the universe.
I like to quote Rumi when
he said, Rumi is so great.
He says why do you stay in prison?
Why do you stay in prison
when the door is wide open?
Please do not stay in this prison.
Ask yourself who am I in the middle
of all this thought traffic?
That's what Rumi also
says in one of his poems.
Who am I in the middle of
all of this though traffic?
And who you are is the
immeasurable potential
of all that was, all that is,
and all that will ever be.
True success comes from self-power.
I'll repeat that.
True success comes from self power.
True success is defined as
the progressive realization
of worthy goals, the ability
to love and have compassion,
and to be in touch with the
creative power inside you,
the ultimate and supreme
genius that mirrors
the wisdom of the universe.
Self-power is true self-esteem.
Self-power is not agency power.
Agency power is outside power
that comes from a title,
from a bank account or
money, from contacts,
or what you might say your
network of connections.
Agency power is weak because it only lasts
as long as the agency lasts.
True power comes from self-esteem,
the core of your being.
It has the following characteristics.
When you have true power,
you are independent
of the good and bad opinions of the world.
You're immune to criticism and flattery
but responsive to feedback.
You're fearless.
You feel beneath no one but
also superior to no one.
When you come from the core of that being
and you ask yourself how can I help,
then you have true power.